c'est johnny moi c'est lui qui me l'a
raconté bassabi t'arriver donc c'est
normal il va dans un va dans un
supermarché c'est geof qui pendant les
vacances l'a décidé dans un supermarché
ce que non bon faire les courses soit on
est en vacances il fait les courses y
poussent le cas dit elle est ici à côté
et où il pousse le caddie pousse le
caddie machin est il pour les trucs et
tout et puis il ya les mecs
d'autres supermarchés qui distribue les
des des biftons de tombola toi comme ça
ils l'ont mais un dans le caddie et tout
est ici à le prendre une petite config
est un peu le ramdam autour c'est johnny
qui dans le supermarché et il entend au
micro ou de de dix minutes est le numéro
un
évidemment les tice à lui fait johnny
c'est toi un talent numéro moi tu fais
mais je m'en fous je peux y aller mais
si sivadier et il y va non mais il y va
il y 20 et le mec déjà mort ni surpris
de voir johnny tu vois combien un commun
et gagner alors à temps il a gagné son
toit il en faisait d'abord non médecins
il a gagné son poids en chocolat bon son
poids parce que c'est la promo en noix
de coco chocolat noix de coco et et 150
euros par jour 150 euros par joueur
jusqu'à ce qu'il fit des bounty
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu